In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinak Sardium for September 13th, on which we commemorate, the Holy
Great Marjorie Ketaven, Queen of Georgia.
Saint Ketaven lived in the 17th century when Georgia was torn apart by the conflicting
interests of two powerful neighbors, the Ottoman Empire and Persia, under Shah Abbas the Great.
As some of the Georgian princes had been brought up in Persia and others in Turkey, the royal
family itself tended to be divided on matters of policy, which added to the weakness of
their country.
Ketaven married David the eldest son of King Alexander II of Georgia, but her husband died
in the year 1601, leaving as heir to the throne his son, Thamuraz, who was sent to the court
of Persia to complete his education.
David's younger brother Constantine, an unscrupulous man, eaten up by ambition, converted to
Shiite Islam and murdered his father, King Alexander II, at the suggestion of Shah Abbas,
in order to rule over the land of Shirvan.
Having committed this crime, he offered to share the throne with his brother's widow,
the devout Queen Ketaven.
She responded by gathering an army that fought and killed the traitor, so that it was the
young Thamuraz, who received the crown on his return from Persia in the year 1606.
Thamuraz was closely allied with his neighbor Luarsob, the King of Kartli, for the same
fervent faith united them. Shah Abbas fomented numerous plots against both these Christian princes
and invaded their kingdoms in the year 1614, deporting and massacring the population,
profaning the churches, and destroying the crosses and the icons with his own hands.
Luarsob and Thamuraz found refuge with the King of Emirathea, who refused to give them up to the
Persians, but the Shah got hold of Luarsob through trickery and held him captive in the fortress
of Shiraz, where after enduring many torments, he was strangled in the year 1622.
In 1615, Shah Abbas invaded the territory of Gandhya to bring Thamuraz into subjection,
so Queen Ketavan, the mother of the unfortunate king, made her way to the Persian court at Shiraz,
accompanied by her young grandsons, Leven, and Alexander to persuade the Shah to spare Georgia.
Abbas agreed on condition of holding hostage the two princes, whom he later castrated,
causing the death of the elder and the younger to go out of his mind.
Queen Ketavan made of her ten-year captivity an aesthetic preparation for martyrdom,
on her refusal to convert to Islam, her body was torn with hooks and red-hot spikes.
Before every torture, the saint made the sign of the cross and said,
in the name of the father and of the son and of the Holy Spirit,
finally, they fixed a cauldron of burning coals on her head and, in her agony, strangled her with a
bowstring. Her glorious martyrdom took place at Shiraz, on the 13th, or 22nd of September,
in the year 1624. Thereafter, a divine light is said to have surrounded the tomb of the Holy Queen
through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us,
and save us.